I was very self-motivated when I was in
school I was taking acting classes at
night I was going to summer stock
theatre you take the blue pill the story
ends you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe since I was
a child I was always asking why we want
you to dive off your board into the
ground
I got bombs and cuts and boards and
elbows your life experience is a
resource you know it's kind of a
resources what you can bring happiness
is uh I guess I could only do like a
kind of a motive run on that which is
like it's all good
he's a Canadian actor producer director
and musician he's best known for his
acting career which began in 1985 and
has spanned more than three decades his
acting career has garnered several
awards including a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame
he's Keanu Reeves and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success I left
home when I was 17 18 I drove from
Toronto Canada to Los Angeles when I was
20 and moved out of my home when I was
18 so the beginning I had you know I
could take care of myself as a teenager
when I moved to the states I had some
family and I had a lot of rejection but
no who did you want to be I mean how how
do you how did you foresee your future
as an actor I didn't I was just wanted
to do it you know I I was very
self-motivated when I was in school I
was taking acting classes at night I was
going to summer stock theatre I was
doing community theater you know I was
just you're simply enjoying it I was
enjoying it but I visit kind of I don't
want to use the word calling you know
but I'm destiny I don't know if it was
destiny it's just what I wanted to do
hey you know but and still you know
hopefully it's doing joying it yeah so
enjoying it and still working at working
like
so he's he's he's letting go of his best
self for for one his own kind of dark
passion to fight to want to have power
but he's using it as like you know but I
have to take care of the temple I have
to take care of my parents I have to
take care of my master and so you know
it's called Tut you know man of Tai Chi
and there's there's these things that we
often times for our we have
responsibilities and so we'll make
sacrifices you know or will be attracted
to something it will make sacrifices to
get something and the film is kind of
promoting the idea that we have to be
thoughtful about that you know that you
can sometimes sacrifice yourself that
you think it's for the good but maybe
there's another way
blue pill a red pill easy red pill okay
what you take the blue pill the story
ends you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe you take
the red pill you stay in Wonderland and
I show you how deep the rabbit-hole goes
remember all I'm offering is the truth
nothing the red pill to me is is a kind
of symbolic taking up of the torch of
trying to understand and to in a way
there's an idealism to it you know it's
almost like to me the red pill
represents the best of who we can
possibly be to ourselves and to other
people
to all sentient beings to nature
everything I trained for the film for
about two months
hanging out with lawyers going to court
working on an accent I did some movement
exercises just for the guy and so by the
time I got to the film I always like Oh
Raffi's is ready since I was a child I
was always asking why used to drive my
everyone around me crazy because it was
like why and how come um so once I said
started working in making movies and
acting in that format I was always
really curious about you know where the
camera was going what was the lens doing
and and also in terms of what everybody
else was doing oh my god I know that's
the thing it's like okay Keanu though
the waves are three feet high I know
here in Hawaii the oceans at the ocean
and I want you to fall off we want you
to dive off your board into the ground
I got bumps and cuts and boards and
elbows and you know jumping and scraping
in but that's fun your life experience
is a resource you know it's kind of a
resources what you can bring you notes
and and so I I kind of describe it just
like there's myself and then there's the
role and the story that you're telling
and you know you bring what you bring
and then you learn and you go to places
that the character will take you to I
know I'm a pretty simple guy you know
you know ever since I was a young kid I
wanted to act you know I started
professional acting when I was fifteen
and you know I've been really lucky to
have the chance to have a career and I
don't know I just have always tried to
keep it simple happiness is uh I guess I
could only do like a kind of a motive
run on that which is like it's all good
everything's good you're feeling good
you're doing something that makes you
feel good you're working with people
loving with people um yeah just it's
it's all good
you
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Jason Rosa Nina asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Keanu's top ten rules had the
biggest impact on you and why would
should you like the most what resonated
with you the most leave it in the
comments and I will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
I don't know I find in my career I've
had a lot of people disagree with me but
I'm okay with that
and I think um you know I think that's
part of the collaboration you know it's
like I have to understand what you're
thinking and feeling you know if you're
acting in the piece if you're the
production designer you know it's this
collaboration of ideas and as long as
you know that I'm always right it's
great right it's perfect what happens if
I don't know that uh then we have to
talk is it like let's meet in private
yeah that we're just okay come with me
and let me just show you how do you
shake it off when you get critiqued uh
drink yeah you know just keep going when
you're working on something for six
months yeah and all of a sudden it comes
out and gets dismissed yes and then you
just get harpooned you get just yeah
it's like yeah it's awful yeah I hate it
yeah you know and you know you hope that
people enter uh enjoy what you do and
when they don't
um it's always a drag and then when you
get harpooned it's like really okay